When you found it, say amen.
>> Read with me. If any of you lack wisdom,
let him ask of God that giveth to all
men liberally and upgradeth not, and it
shall be given him. Now, don't put any
text on the screen. I want you to open
your Bibles.
>> Who is the text man? Don't put any text
on the screen. Just take them off. Open
your Bibles, please.
Sometimes I wish I had the power to
strike all cell phones dead for one
hour. Just an hour. So that you have to
open your Bible. Now who can recite the
Bible from Genesis to Revelation? The
books in order. Genesis to Revelation.
Come.
Here comes a daughter, a child of God.
One day she'll be in the kingdom and
she'll get wings, but she has no. She's
a mallaya bila mawa right now.
Okay. Genesis revelation.
Okay. um Genesis, Exodus, Leviticus,
Numbers, Deuteronomy, Joshua, Judges,
Ruth, 1 Samuel, 2 Samuel, 1 Kings, 2
Kings, 1 Chronicles, 2 Chronicles, Ezra,
Nemiah, Esther, Job, Psalms, Proverbs,
Ecclesiastes, Song of Solomon, Isaiah,
Jeremiah,
Lamentations,
Ezekiel, Daniel, Hosea,
Joel, Amos, Oadiah, Micah,
Oh.
Oh, yeah. Jonah and then Micah. And then
um we have Nahome, Habacook, Zephaniah,
Hagi, Zechariah, Malachi. Then we have
Matthew, Ma, Matthew, Mark, Luke, John,
Acts, um Romans, 1 Corinthians, 2
Corinthians,
and then um we have Galatians,
Ephesians, Philippians, Colossians, 1
Thessalonians, 2 Thessalonians, 1
Timothy, 2 Timothy, Titus, Filimmon, and
then we have Hebrews, James, 1 and 2
Peter, uh 1, 2, 3 John, Jude,
Revelation,
God bless you. God bless you. I really
mean that.
>> God bless you, Bintiongu. Okay.
All right. Notice James 1:5 again. If
any of you lack wisdom, let him ask of
God, which giveth to all men how?
Liberally, and upgradeth not, and it
shall be given him. But let him ask how
in faith. Verse six, nothing wavering.
What do you understand by nothing
wavering?
Don't doubt.
For he that waverth is as a wave of the
sea driven with the wind and tossed. Let
not that man think that he shall receive
anything from the Lord. Doubt displeases
God. Now wisdom of course is in God's
word. So don't just ask God for wisdom
and ignore Bible study.
The wisdom comes through the word of
God. So let's pray and ask God for
wisdom now. Our father in heaven, we
thank you for the continuous of the the
continuation of this holy day. We thank
you, God, for the blessings you've given
us, spiritual and material. If we've
offended you, forgive us, Father. Now,
dear God, we commit this service to your
glory as we try to answer some
questions. Grant wisdom, grant us
insight, de God, but also grant us the
willingness to live by what we learn.
Bless us, we pray in Jesus' name. Amen.
Was that the first question, pastor? The
one you asked. Okay. As a matter of
devotion, Bible study, memorization,
I was talking to my dear brother
earlier,
I um I just try
to interact with God's word
morning to night.
I was telling him if I'm driving
somewhere,
you can bet your life I'm reciting
something while I'm driving. There are
some Bible passages I recite the music.
And so I have the music playing an
Amoris like uh John 17
um the the the prodigal son Luke 11 Luke
15:11-32
or the prayer of forgiveness Psalm 51 or
the prayer of creation Psalm 139 or
Daniel telling Nebuchadnezzar about the
dream Daniel 2 1-19 you know all these
and then the Elawite passages I recite
to music so that I'm always always
always always trying to stay in touch
with the word of God or with Ellaw
White's quotations. So literally if I'm
driving
I'm reciting.
I told my pastor if I go to the bathroom
the church
while I'm in there I am reciting
something.
It's no joke.
And uh if I'm brushing my teeth,
sometimes I brush my teeth like this.
I'm brushing and there's a Bible on the
the what do you call that little thing
in the bathroom? That's whatever it is.
And I Mhm.
If I'm learning something, I'm trying to
review it. You know, the little sink
stand and that's how I do it.
So I'm always always always
um if I'm flying, that's what I do.
I try to encourage others to do it. So I
have someone doing it with me. And there
are people all over the world who trying
to memorize the word of God. Young, old,
in between, all over.
One of the benefits of memorizing
scripture is that you can do a Bible
study in your head. You see what I'm
trying to say? You don't you you learn a
new passage and some other passage comes
to your mind. People say to me, "How do
you preach without notes?" Well, because
the notes are in my head.
Are you following me? These are notes
from heaven. You just put them together
and you speak. And as you're speaking,
the Lord brings things to your head you
hadn't planned. But God can't bring to
your mind a text you've never learned.
Are you following me? And so I try. I'm
not saying I'm Mr. Righteous, Mr. Holy,
none of that. I'm simply saying I like
doing it. I like memorizing. Uh there's
a psalm I try to recite at least once a
day. Psalm 78. It has 72 verses. And I
try to say it every day, sometimes twice
a day, so I can have it in my head. Have
it in my head. There's some Psalms I try
to say every day. Psalms 78. They call
historical Psalms. 78, 103, 104. Well,
105, 106, 107, historical 136, and 78.
The historical Psalms. They record God's
dealing with the Israelites. And some
say the same thing but differently. So
now you can compare what 105 says with
106 or 107 or 78. And of course since
I'm an evangelist I have to know God's
word. You understand? But for my own
spiritual benefit you know Jesus told
the disciples in John 15:3 you clean
through the word which I have spoken
unto you. In Ephesians 5:25, the Bible
says, "Husbands, love your wives even as
Christ also loved the church and gave
himself for it, that he might sanctify
and cleanse it with the washing of water
by the word, that he might present it to
himself a glorious church, not having
spot or wrinkle or any such thing, but
that it should be holy and without
blemish." And the method Christ uses is
his word. El White tells us in Christ
object lessons page 100 paragraph one if
studied and obeyed the word of God works
in the heart subduing every unholy
attribute
it subdues pornography violence lying
whatever it's it doesn't do it overnight
but continual exposure will remove these
things
she also says Christ object lessons page
125 paragraph Three. If the follower of
Christ will believe his word and
practice it, give me another word for
practice it. Obey. There is no science
in the natural world. He will not be
able to grasp and appreciate. She's
saying if you get this in your head,
science becomes easier.
And so I try to make this the foundation
of my mind so others subjects of study
can become easier to grasp. Are you
following me? And for those of you in
school, you're struggling with
physiology or whatever. If the follower
of Christ will believe his word and
practice it, there is no science in the
natural world, he will not be able to
grasp, meaning to understand it
intellectually, appreciate, make the
connection with God.
And so I uh
I if I get up in the middle of the
night, I start to recite.
Mhm.
Um
I just try to do it all day. That's all.
All day. All day. All day. Learning new,
reciting the old. I'm now working on
Exodus 34. Beautiful chapter. Uh
beautiful, beautiful chapter. I'm also
working on Jeremiah 27.
and um 1 Corinthians 2 and 3 and other
chapters at the same time. So you're
reciting the old adding new passages,
but you have to go over them over and
over and over. Alawite writes in um
ministry of healing page 491 paragraph 3
that which at first seems difficult
by constant repetition grows easy
and right thoughts and actions become
habitual. Well, I was in South Africa a
few years ago preaching in Suetto and uh
I met an elder. He used to be a
professional golfer. Very nice man. And
he told me when he was a golfer about
every day or so he
what kind of thing drives or whatever
you called him. You hit the ball about
600 times a day. A swing. Okay. A swing
about 600 times just to you see you do
something over and over. You come to the
point where you don't have to think
about it. You just do it. It's called
muscle memory. It works mentally as
well. You see these expert basketball
players, they do their practice over and
over and over. Some of us are caught in
sin because we do it over and over and
over. Now, if we do righteousness over
and over and over, it has the opposite
effect. The Bible says in 2 Timothy
3:16, "All scripture is given by
inspiration of God and is profitable for
doctrine, for reproof, for correction."
What's the last one? Instruction in
righteousness. This is it. And so I
recommend to you this as preparation for
anything and everything. Lomi says the
best preparation for any line of work is
the word of God.
So I try to stay with it and it's also
my work. A carpenter should know how to
use his tools. Am I right? This is my
tool for the work I do as an evangelist.
All right. Any other question?
Yes, my pastor.
Mhm.
>> Mhm. Mhm.
[Laughter]
My wife's a spiritual lady, so that's
not a problem at all. She loves the Lord
himself very much. Um, and I have no
children, so that makes it very very
easy. So, no, there's no problem there.
She's a very spiritual lady. Always
online, listening to sermons, reading
books and doing that. So, that doesn't
that doesn't trouble her at all. Of
course, when I have to travel, she
wishes I'd come back immediately. But,
uh, no, it's it's a supportive
environment, and she understands what I
have to do. This is my work. And when I
recite, I do it quietly. So she's not
disturbed. Some reciting I do in my
head, but I do a lot of it out loud.
When I say out loud, I just orally
because I'll tell you something about
reciting and memorizing. You can
memorize something, but you can't say it
publicly. The reason is you're not
accustomed hearing yourself say it. You
see, that's a problem. So you know
quietly, for God so loved the world, you
know it. But the moment you say it,
you're not accustomed saying it. So you
run into problems. So memorization
requires when you recite, recite out
loud. So you you get accustomed to
hearing yourself say these words, you
see, and you don't run into trouble. But
no, there's no such thing. This is my
work. She knows that. And uh and she
lets me do it. God bless her.
Oh
well,
I can only give you advice. The Bible,
you know, people write me say, "What's
your take on this?" I say, "I have no
take." Here's what the Bible says. I
have no take on anything. Here's what
the Bible says.
The very first commandment, I'll come to
you my handsome brother. The very first
commandment says, "Thou shalt have what?
No other gods before me." That applies
in every situation, whether it's
marriage, courtship, work, education,
romance, recreation, socialization, you
name it. Thou shalt have no other gods
before me. And the biggest favor that a
man can do to his family is put God
first. That's the biggest favor you can
do. Put God first.
And if you have a godly wife, she
understands that. So God first.
And when that's the case, he takes care
of everything under that. If he's not
first, then you're headed for trouble at
some level. But if he is first,
then he takes care of everything else.
Everything else. All right? God is a God
who tightens. God doesn't break up
families. God builds families. Are you
following me? He builds them. He doesn't
break them up, but he builds them his
way so that they enter the eternal
kingdom. Are you with me? There's a
secular way to build a family, which is
put God aside and take care of earthly
things. The Bible's way is God first and
he'll take care of everything else.
>> Never change that order. God first. Seek
ye first the kingdom of God, whether
you're single or you're married.
Exodus, Jeremiah, 1 Corinthians. Mhm.
>> Is there for There's no formula. Each
person will bring to it an
individuality. There's no formula.
because I'm working on Exodus 34, um,
Jeremiah 27, 1 Corinthians 2. I'm
working on I try to say them all the
time while going over all the other
stuff that I already know plus ly
quotations. But so right now my priority
is those three. Exodus 34, Jeremiah 27,
1 Corinthians uh 2, and I'm adding 1
Corinthians 3. Uh, so those those are my
priorities. and um perfecting Hagi and
Malachi. So these are the ones occupying
my time right now.
Uh-huh.
Oh, is there no there's no there's no
set uh list that I have. I may decide
let me now do Ezekiel 36. And I just
wrote Ezekiel 36. Now my next target
would be Isaiah 43:44 45 because I like
those three chapters. You following me?
They deal so much as Christ as God. And
I like that Christ as God the redee. You
read those three chapters you see it's
clear that the mighty God is Jesus
Christ. Mhm. So I want those. I have to
get them precisely as they written. So
I'll go to those next when I'm finished
what I'm working on now.
Yes.
>> Yep. Yeah. Some chap some chapters are
challenging and you've got to go over
them over for for instance this will
come to mind
Genesis chapter 14. Now it came to pass
in the days of Amriel king of Shina,
Ariel, king of Allesa, Kedle, king of
Elam, and Tidel, king of nations, that
these made war with Bera, king of Sodom,
and with Bersa, king of Gomorrah,
Shinam, king of Admma, and Shemiba, the
king of Zabo, which is Bailah. These all
these were joined together in the veil
of Sidim, which is a salt sea. 12 years
they served Ketellar Roma and in the
13th year they rebelled. And in the 14th
year came Kedler and the kings that were
with him and smought the Rafaims in
Asharoth Carname and the Zuzims in Ham
and the emms in Shave Kerthim and the
Horites in the Mount Serion which is by
the wilderness and they returned and
came to en Mishbat which is Kadesh and
smote all the country of the Amalachites
and also the Amorites that dwelt in
Heson Tamar. Now you have to go through
that over and over and over to get these
funny names in your head.
But I regard that as a challenge.
You understand? And God has to help me.
But the same way someone says, "What's
your name?" Randolph Anthony Ski. Are
you following me? I want to be able to
say, "Then again, Abraham took a wife
and her name was Ketura and she bare him
Zimr and Joan and Maiden and Midian and
Ishbach and Shua." Because Abraham ended
up with eight sons, not just two. He had
eight. So as well as I know Ishmael and
Isaac, I wanted to know Ziman, Joan,
Midan, Midian, Ishbach, and Shua. But I
had to go through that over and over and
over. Mhm. Got to do that like learning
some details in medical school or
something over and I also try to
memorize other things to strengthen the
brain like the 12 cranial nerves in
order. I'm not a doctor but I just
memorized those uh all African countries
in alphabetical order you know I
memorize those you know from Algeria
down to Zimbabwe just to expose the mind
and challenge the mind all European
countries in order all South American
countries in order 50 states in order
just to challenge the mind by the way
when you expose your mind to different
experiences the brain develops new cells
Mhm.
to accommodate this new it develops new.
You can regenerate your brain by
exposing it to a new
and nothing will generate the brain more
than this because this the encyclopedia
britannica is not alive. This is alive.
And so I recommend this to you with no
hesitation whatsoever.
>> This is my defense against Alzheimer's.
Are you following me? Now, this
statement has not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration, but this
is my protection against Alzheimer's.
The word of God living in the head. Oh,
I re Now, Elise said, if children read
the Bible, they would realize is the is
the most exciting book on earth, but
they spend so much time in secular
things with parental permission
that the Bible becomes the most boring
thing in the world. And that's a sad,
it's a tragedy that the most exciting
book becomes the most boring.
You see, your brain takes the shape of
the material to which it is exposed.
When I say the shape, the the tone, the
temper. If you expose it to games, it
comes to place where it can only
appreciate games. And then the Bible,
you know, he said, "Thou shalt not
kill." And you don't understand what
that means because your brain has been
affected by all the exposure to secular
things that have no bearing on your
spiritual life. All right. Next
question. Some Bible question. Now get
the focus off me.
Some Bible question.
If you came all week. Okay. Ladies
first. Is that okay? All right. Okay.
>> Mhm.
Well, Christ is eternal.
You can't trace Christ's genealogy. But
MelkiseDC has no genealogy that's
recorded either. You understand? Without
father, without mother. That's
MelkiseDC. Christ has the Melkisedc
priesthood because Christ is without
beginning or end. And MelkiseDC was a
real person by the way. He was not
Jesus. He was a real person. But the
Bible gives no genealogy for MelkiseDC.
Almost as if he's always been there. And
so Christ's priesthood is modeled on
Melkisedc.
No beginning, no end. Mhm. No father, no
mother. Mhm.
But Christ is prophet, priest, and king.
MelkiseDC was priest and king. Christ is
prophet, priest, and king. Yes. Thank
you, my brother.
Does it matter? Yes. Oh, yes. There's
some versions I never recommend like the
Living Bible.
Uh, no. No.
God, you see, God can get the truth into
your heart. If depending on what you if
this is all you have, whatever it is,
God knows how to get through to you. But
you have to believe. You see, the
devil's most important strategy is
deception.
Lying is the twisting of truth.
You must understand the devil has his
Bibles.
If you don't believe that, then you're a
very kind person to the devil. The devil
must have his versions. There's a Bible
version called, you're all familiar with
the King James version. Do you know
there's a Bible called the Queen James
Version?
The fact that a book says Bible doesn't
make it safe.
Know people talk about gospel aerobics.
That doesn't make it safe.
Adding the word gospel does not make
something good. Adding the word Bible
doesn't make anything good. It's the
content. There's the Queen James which I
believe uh takes out or deals with eight
or so verses that deal with
homosexuality. And those who don't like
that wanted a version that does not
condemn that kind of behavior. There's a
Bible that all refers to God as she.
I think it's a feminist Bible. And so
you cannot say every Bible is good. Now
if you end up with a Bible that calls
God she and that is all you have and God
sees your heart. You see he'll find a
way to get the truth to you. But you've
got to do some of your research and
determine which is the safest versions
to follow.
Me the one I use to study. I consult
many versions. Let me say that clearly
when I'm studying. But when I'm
memorizing or when I'm preaching, I just
use the King James version. One of the
reasons I like about it, it is in the
public domain.
What do I mean by that? If you write a
book and you quote from the NIV or you
have to say with permission of,
are you following me? You've got to get
permission if you quote too many verses.
The King James you don't have to do
that. I think it's only the queen. I
think England maybe has some control
over it, but generally the King James,
you can quote and quote as much as you
like. The other reason why I like the
King James version because the Catholics
don't the Catholic Church didn't like it
when it came out. You understand? So I
figure if the Catholic Church doesn't
like it, I'm going to like it.
It was once banned, but the the the the
um the American Standard Version is
good. the other version, New American
Standard Version. You you do your
research and figure out which ones are
accurate translations
and which ones are more commentaries.
But you have God to lead you, father,
which which version should I use?
But don't assume that everyone is fine
because it has the word Bible on it.
There's one written by an Adventist guy
called the Clear Word. That's a
commentary. That's not a translation.
It's helpful, but it's not a
translation.
It's a commentary. One man's view of
what the Bible should say. All right.
Somebody else. Oh, yes, my brother. In
the blue shirt. In the Bible, blue
stands for obedience. So, you have a
good color. Oh, I have blue as well.
Okay. Yes.
The New International Version. I don't
recommend. Well, I don't want it as
mine.
If you read
books from former Adventists that attack
our sanctuary doctrines,
most of the texts are from NIV, not the
King James. NIV. I once asked a scholar
at Andrews University, a Bible scholar,
if we had to use one version only to
defend our truths, which one would come
closest to being able to do that? And he
told me the King James version. I'm not
saying it's a perfect translation. None
of them is perfect. But if we had to
choose one version, use this one alone
and defend the basic doctrines of this
church. He told me it'd be the King
James version.
Also, the NIV leaves out a lot of
passages that are in the King James
version.
You have to compare them. Compare them.
Compare them.
Satan is so clever. A translation only
needs to twist one verse to cause
problems. For instance, in um in Hebrews
11 verse 21, by faith, Jacob when he was
dying blessed both the sons of Joseph
and worshiped leaning upon the top of
his staff.
Hebrews 11:21, I think it is. One
version says that Jo Jacob worshiped the
top of his staff.
That'd be very pleasing to the
Catholics, Jacob worshiped the top of
his staff. So he's worshiping an idol.
Do you understand? But the translation
says, which is reliable, and he
worshiped leaning because he was an old
man and his sight wasn't good. Leaning
on the staff. One version said worship.
Now there's not a Bible that says
confess your sins one to another.
If you accept that, then the church can
say a priest can forgive you. But the
Bible says, "Confess your faults."
So you have to be careful. You may take
a translation as generally good, but
there's some there's some verses that
are troublesome and significantly
troublesome. So you have to uh choose
your version carefully.
Ask God, do some research and the Lord
will lead you accordingly.
All right. Yes, my brother.
Trinity. Yes.
In authority. Yes.
No. No. No. Okay. Good question. All
right. Good. Okay. Let me pray again.
Father, now I'm on the Trinity.
Give me really precise language. I pray
that I may answer this to your glory and
our enlightenment in Jesus name. Amen.
Go to uh John 3.
It's 3:25. I'll be done as well. When
does the sun set?
How many of you have to rush off to work
in half an hour? No. Okay. John 3. Oh,
you have to go to work in half an hour.
Okay. Let's read verse eight.
John 3:8.
Do you have that? Not yet.
Read it for me. The wind bloweth where
it listeth, and thou hearth the sound
thereof, but can't not tell whence it
cometh or whether it goeth. Now, very,
very carefully finish that verse. So is
everyone that is born of the spirit. In
other words, the spirit brings about a
birth. What's that birth called? The new
birth. Give me another expression for
the new birth.
Conversion.
The spirit does that.
Only God can bring about conversion.
What am I trying to say? The Holy Spirit
is divine.
Fully divine. Go to 1 Corinthians 2.
1 Corinthians 2. We'll read from verse
9.
Are you there?
Read for me. What does that say? But
>> 1 Corinthians 2:9,
but I have not seen nor ear heard,
neither have entered into the heart of
man, the things which God hath prepared
for them that love him. Now, but God
hath revealed him to us. How? By his
spirit. Keep reading. For the spirit
what searchth stop how many things?
But what are these all things? Keep
reading.
>> Yeah. The ah
everything God knows. Come on, talk to
me. The Holy Spirit knows.
Only God, a divine being can know
everything another divine being knows.
The Holy Spirit is fully God.
When I say they have different
functions, I'm not saying one is less
divine than the other. You see, when God
said, "Let us make man in our image,"
the image of God is not only the
character. The image of God is also seen
in a marriage arrangement with a man
who's head of the home. Are you
following me? Are you following me?
That's the image of God. The marriage
arrangement is also the image of God.
Now, here's a man, here's a woman. Each
one is 100% a part of that union. Are
you following me? But who is the head?
The husband. Now, you have a family. You
have husband, wife, child.
Each one is 100% a family member. But
how does the line of authority go? The
father, come on. The mother, the child,
but each one is 100% family.
The heavenly family, father, son, holy
spirit. Each one fully divine. Go to
Psalm 104. Let me show you what I mean.
Psalm 104. Read verse
30 of Psalm 104.
Verse 30 of Psalm 104.
Are you there? Read nice and loud. What
does that say?
>> Thou sendest forth thy spirit. Come on.
>> They are created. And thou renewest the
face of the earth. What does that verse
tell us? The spirit can do
>> create.
Only God can create. Creation in the
Bible, the word for create is only used
for God. The Holy Spirit can create. The
Holy Spirit brings about a new birth.
Only God can do that. Let's go to Isaiah
46.
Let's read verses 9 and 10 of Isaiah 46
or just nine. Are you there? Read with
me. Remember
the former things of old. I am and
theirs.
>> I am and
keep reading. Declaring the end from the
beginning and from ancient times with
things that are not yet done. Stop. What
is this ability of God that the text is
talking about?
All knowing. Mhm. He knows the end and
the beginning. He's all knowing. Go now
to First Peter chapter 1.
First Peter 1.
Let's read from verse
verse 9 just to make we'll go all the
way to 11. Are you there?
>> Read with me. receiving the end of your
faith, even the salvation of your souls,
of which salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched diligently, who
prophesied of the grace that should come
onto you. Pause. When the Old Testament
prophets were writing, they were trying
to understand what they were writing.
They wanted to be alive when Jesus came.
That's what they were told to write, but
they did not fully understand. Verse 11.
Searching what? Or what manner of time?
Carefully now the spirit of Christ which
was in them did signify when it
testified beforehand the sufferings of
Christ and the glory that should be.
>> Mhm. Now what spirit was leading the the
the the uh prophets?
>> Spirit of Christ or the Holy Spirit. Now
the Holy Spirit told them things that
had not yet happened. Now, who is the
first prophet in the Bible?
Enoch. Very good. Whoever said that,
give you 100% for that answer. Enoch.
Now, let's see what the Holy Spirit told
Enoch. Go to Jude. Jude has one chapter.
So, he just called the verse. Jude.
Let's read 14 of the book of Jude.
That's just before Revelation. The book
of Jude.
We have Jude. Let's read from verse 14.
And Enoch also the seventh from Adam
prophesied of these sayings, saying,
"Behold, the Lord cometh with 10,000 of
his saints to do what? Execute judgment
of all and to convince all that are of
all the ungodly
sinners." Now
the Lord cometh with what
is that? What is Jon uh not Jonah Enoch
prophesying about
the second coming?
Now read verse 14 again. And Enoch also
the seventh from Adam. Here's what we
have. If you count the patriarchs, Adam,
Seth, Enos, Kanan, Mahalil, Jared,
Enoch. When Enoch was alive, Adam was
still alive.
They lived together about 300 years.
As far back as the days of Adam,
someone was talking about the second
coming.
But not only the second coming,
the third coming.
Why do I say that? At the second coming,
there's no real judgment that's
executed.
Are you with me? Judgment is executed at
the third coming when all the wicked are
destroyed.
Now that's six 7,000 years from Jo uh
Enoch's time. Who told him that? The
Holy Spirit. How can the Holy Spirit
know something over that expanse of
time? Because the Holy Spirit is divine.
Knows the end from the beginning. Are
you following me? Now go to Isaiah 45.
Isaiah 45.
We read verse 22.
No, Isaiah 45:22.
That's okay, my sister. Isaiah 45 verse
22. Let's read now. Look unto me and be
saved. All the ends are there. For I am
and there is. What is that verse saying?
When he says, "I am God, there's none
else." What is he saying?
No one else can save. He said, "Look to
me and be saved." I am God, there's no
one else can save but me. But we read in
John 3:8, "The wind bloweth where it
listeth, and thou hearest the sound
thereof, but can not tell whence it
cometh or whether it goeth. So is
everyone that is born of the spirit."
That's salvation. The spirit must be
divine. It is he that brings about the
new birth through the word of God. The
spirit is involved in salvation. Let's
go to creation. Let's go to Genesis 1.
I told you the Bible uses the word for
create only in application to God. Now,
Genesis 1, reading from verse one.
In the beginning, God created the heaven
and the earth. Verse two. And the earth
was without form and void, and darkness
was upon the face of the deep, and the
spirit of God moved upon the face. As a
matter of fact, the very first member of
the Godhead identified by name in the
Bible is the Holy Spirit. He was
involved. We know the central figure of
creation is Jesus Christ, but the spirit
was involved. So, we have the spirit who
can create, who can save, who knows the
end from the beginning. And those three
things apply to God, a divine being.
Now, so we have the spirit, we have the
son, we have the father in an ascending
order of authority.
Make the difference between authority
and essence. They are all the same as
far as divinity is concerned. Are you
with me? But they have different
responsibilities. Now go to John 14.
John 14.
Read for me verse 26.
But the comforter which is the whom the
father shall send in my name, he shall
find. Now what does Jesus say will
happen?
Okay. Okay. But what else does he say
before that? What does he say about the
comforter whom the father come on?
>> Who sends the comforter in that verse?
the father. What did we learn this
morning about who sends and who sent?
The one who sends has more authority. He
sends the Holy Spirit. Now go to John 15
and read verse 26. John 15 26.
This will surprise you a little bit. Are
you there? Read for me now. But when the
comforter who's come, come on. whom I
will send unto you from the father. Even
the spirit of truth that proceedth from
the father he shall now I will send him
says Jesus. What does that tell you
about the relationship between Jesus and
the holy spirit? Jesus has high
authority in his divinity not in his
humanity.
Go to Luke 4.
Luke chapter 4.
Read verse 18.
The spirit of the Lord is upon me. Keep
reading. He hath anointed me to do what?
Preach the gospel. Yeah. The spirit when
Christ was human, the spirit led him.
But in his divinity, he tells the spirit
what to do. So both the father and the
son can send the spirit. But in his
humanity, Jesus depended on the spirit.
In his divinity, he sends the spirit. Am
I clear?
Father, son, holy spirit are equally
divine. They have different functions.
Now
Jesus, go to Ephesians 3. Let's look at
the relation between Jesus and the
father with respect to authority.
Ephesians 3. Let's read verse 9.
And to make all men see what is the
fellowship of the mystery which
from the beginning of the world have
been hidden God who created all things
by ah
who created
but for whom?
Don't hesitate. Jesus created but for at
the at the request of the father. The
verse says the father created in other
words the father wants creation and
Jesus you do it. So Jesus was the one
who said let there be like but acting as
an agent of the father. Go to Hebrews
chapter 1.
Hebrews 1.
Let me know when you've reached Hebrews
1.
God who at sunundry times and in diverse
manners, reading from verse one, spake
in time past unto the fathers by the
prophets, hath in these last days spoken
unto us how? By his son. Read carefully
now. Whom he hath appointed heir of all
things by whom also he made the worlds.
The father used Christ to do creating.
We have that in Hebrews 1:2, Galat uh
Ephesians 3:9.
This is the relationship between son and
father. The son does the bidding of the
father. Now go to Ephesians chapter 2.
Not Ephesians, Philippians 2.
That's putting the cherry on the cake.
Philippians chapter 2.
Let's read from verse 8. From verse
five, so we can read the Bible. From
verse 5 of Philippians chapter 2.
Let this mind be in you which was also
in Christ Jes. By the way, not let a
similar mind, the same mind Christ had
is the mind you and I to use as we live
on this earth. Let this mind be in you
which was also in Christ Jesus, who
being in the form of God, thought it not
robbery to be equal with God, but made
himself of no reputation, took upon him
the form of a servant, and was made in
the likeness of men. And being found in
fashion as a man, he humbled himself and
became obedient unto death, even the
death of the cross. Wherefore God also
hath highly exalted him. Keep reading.
And given him a name, come on. Which is
above every name. Now read carefully.
That at the name of Jesus every knee
should bow of things
>> and things and earth and things and the
earth. and that every tongue should
>> that Jesus Christ is now finish the
verse to the glory of God the father.
Mhm. The ultimate aim is the glory of
the father.
Mhm.
They are equal in divinity. I usually do
it like this. Equal. Each one is fully
divine but different in authority. Are
you following me? Equal in divinity,
different in authority.
The fact that the Holy Spirit serves the
father does not make the Holy Spirit any
less divine. No one is less than the
other in their substance. They are only
different in their function. And that's
part of the image of God. Now, let me
ask you this.
Who is the highest angel in heaven?
Gabriel now. Yeah.
Is there any angel higher than Gabriel?
No.
But are all are all angels angels? Yes.
But Gabriel has greatest authority in
heaven.
It even exists among demons.
Go to Luke chapter 11. Let's read from
verse 24. Luke 11. Reading from verse
24.
Are you there?
Not yet. Luke was a medical doctor. He
was not one of the 12 disciples, but he
traveled sometimes with Paul. Luke wrote
the book of Luke. What other book did
Luke write? The book of Acts. Yes. Do
you have Luke 11? Read from verse 24.
What does that say? When the unclean
spirit has gone out of man, he walketh
through dry places seeking rest. Cut
reading. And finding none, he saith what
I will. Unto my house. Come on.
When I came,
when he cometh, he findeth it sweat and
garnish. Carefully now. Then goeth he.
Come on. And take to him
seven other spirits. What?
>> More wicked. Now pause. What do you
understand by more wicked? You see this?
The the fallen angels were once,
come on. Come on.
The evil angels were once good angels
and they had levels of authority. When
they were thrown out, they left with the
same power. So even demons now, some are
more powerful than others.
Are you with me? Because they brought
that with them when they were thrown out
of heaven. Good angels have the same
system. Evil angels, some are more
powerful. Ly says the demon of
inmperence can't control yourself is a
giant
a giant.
That's why she says in tempmperance lies
at a foundation of all the moral evils
known to man. Satan assigns the demon of
inmperance. Lomi say he is a giant.
When he grabs you,
you've been grabbed.
But they're all demons.
different levels of power.
And so this concept of different levels
of authority is part of the image of
God. Let me ask you this. Did God set up
a system of priests? Yes or no?
Who was the high priest?
Aaron, the first one. Are there some
privileges Aaron had that the average
Levite did not have? Yes. Who could go
into the most holy place on the day of
atonement? Only the high priest. Now a
Levite could say, "Come on, man. I've
been baptized just like you. Why can't I
go? If you want to die, go."
It was not his privilege, but they were
all part of the priesthood.
But the high priest alone could go into
that holy place. And so God's image has
levels of authority.
The king was the ruler of the
Israelites. He had privileges the
average Israelite did not have.
The Bible says, "Let the elders that
rule well be counted worthy of double
honor."
Go to uh Hebrews chapter 13.
Hebrews 13. Then we'll get to another
question. Hebrews 13.
This is one of the problems in the
church, by the way. The church does not
respect authority.
Hebrews 13, someone read verse 7
carefully for me. What does that say?
Remember them.
Wait a minute. What do you understand by
have the rule over you church leaders?
Uh-huh.
Now read verse 17.
Obey them. They have rule over you. Read
verse 23.
24.
with all them that have the Mhm. over
and over. Paul says, "Look, say hi to
the root, the leaders of the church,
those with authority over you."
Now, go to Numbers 21.
See how dangerous it is to disregard
God's leadership.
Numbers 21,
read verse five.
And the people spoke against Aaron,
against Moses,
and against God. Mhm. Against Moses and
against God.
Opposing God's dulyeleed leadership is
opposing God. When I say oppose, you can
disagree, but you can't disrespect.
Are you following me? You can't. Well,
you can if you want to, but you should
not disrespect God's leadership. Now,
did Jesus know the priest in his day
were largely corrupt? Yes. Go to Matthew
chapter 8.
Let's read from verse one of Matthew 8.
Do you have that?
When he came down from the mount, great
multitudes followed him. And behold,
there came a leper, worshiped him,
saying, Lord, if thou wilt, thou canst
make me clean. And Jesus put forth his
hand, and touched him, saying, What? I
will be thou clean. And immediately his
leprosy was cleansed. Now read verse
four. Jesus said unto him, see thou tell
no man, but go thy way. Short thyself.
Stop. Go finish the verse. And offer the
gift Moses commanded as a testimony.
Okay. Now Jesus told this man, Jesus
knew the priests were corrupt, but the
system was only a priest could declare
someone free from leprosy. So even
though God healed him,
Jesus said, "Go to the priest." He
respected the authority of the let the
priest make the final declaration. I
healed you, but I'm God.
Go to Luke 17.
Luke 17. Let's read from verse 11.
And it came to pass as he went to
Jerusalem, he passed through the midst
of Samaria and Galilee. Keep reading.
And as he entered into the certain
village, they met him 10 men that were
stood a far off. And they lift up their
voices and said what? Jesus, master,
have mercy on us. When he saw them, he
did what? He said unto them, "Go show
yourselves to the priest."
Again,
Christ did everything he could to
respect the structure of authority in
that even though he was God. Now, when
God heals you, why does someone else
have to declare you healed?
You have to respect the authority of the
church.
All right?
Father, Son, Holy Ghost, equally divine.
They simply have different functions.
That's all.
By the way, when you pray, pray to the
Father, not the Holy Spirit.
Are you with me? I've heard people pray,
"Dear Holy Spirit." The Bible never
calls you to pray to the Holy Spirit.
Go to John 17.
Let's look at our example, and that's
Jesus. John 17.
Let me pray again. Father, as I
continue, continue to guide us with your
wisdom. I pray in Jesus' name. Amen.
Let's read from verse three. And this is
life eternal that they might know. No,
let's read from verse two. From one.
These words spake Jesus and lifted up
his eyes to heaven and said what?
Father. To whom did he pray? The father.
Did the Holy Spirit exist? Yes. Did he
pray to the Holy No. Father? Go to verse
5.
And now, oh father, yes, read verse uh
11.
Nowhere in the world, but these are in
the world, and I come to thee. Come on,
holy father.
That's three times. Let's go to verse
24.
Read verse 21. 21. What does that say?
that it all may be one as thou father
that's four times read 24
father I will that they whom thou will
give me be with me where I am that's
five times read 25 oh righteous father
now stop you tell me to whom did Jesus
pray
>> was the holy spirit existing did he pray
to the holy spirit he pray to the father
go to Matthew
Matthew 6.
Let's read from verse 9. You know it
very well. You can say it without
looking. But if you want to look, look.
Matthew 6. Read verse 9. Read for me.
After this manner, therefore pray ye our
father. So our father. Go to John 11.
Yes. John chapter 11.
Let's read from verse 39 of John 11.
We're at the tomb of Lazarus. Read for
me. What does that say?
Jesus said, "Take him with a stone."
Martha, the sister of him that was dead
said, "Lord, by this time he stinkketh."
Keep reading. Jesus said unto her, "Said
not I unto thee that if thou was
believed, thou should do what? See the
glory of God." Then they took away the
stone from the place where the dead was
laid. Keep reading. Then Jesus lifted up
his eyes and said what? Stop.
When Christ was on the cross and he
prayed for those who crucified him, what
did he say? Father, forgive them. Now
you tell me to whom did Jesus pray? The
father.
Okay. To whom should you pray? The
but in the name of Jesus.
Because anything God does for you, he
does because of the sacrifice of Christ.
And that includes every breath you're
taking now. Remove the sacrifice of
Christ, you'd all collapse. And so would
I. I'd probably collapse first.
Okay. Ask me another question. Yes, my
brother.
Uhhuh.
>> Look at what?
>> Mhm.
>> Traditions that are not from our
pioneers.
That's what you're saying. Well, our
guidance is not what the pioneers do.
Our guidance is the Bible. Because the
pioneers were frequently the pioneers
used to smoke at one point. They they
enjoyed pork and other point. The
pioneers didn't pay tithe at one point.
So, you know, truth grows and develops.
We are to be guided by
this.
Now, God gave us the council of Ellen
White. That's number two. Now, but let
me be quick to say the pioneers wrote a
lot of things that are absolutely
precious.
But they were developing in the
understanding of truth. At one point
some pioneers believe that Jesus had a
beginning.
I mean even James White I think at one
point believed that then he gave that
up. At one point some pioneers did not
believe in the Holy Spirit.
So some of them had to grow and develop
in the understanding. We are not to be
led by tradition. We're to be led by
thus sayth the Lord. And so if you study
the lives of the pioneers and you find
some problems, God judges you for the
time in which you live and your
circumstances. What opportunities, what
light did you have and how did you you
see God doesn't if God gives you only
this amount of light, that's all he
requires of you.
If you have this much light and you're
this much faithful, you're failed. If
you have this much light and you're this
much faithful, you're fine with God. So,
it's not tradition. It is thus sayth the
Lord. Sunday as the Sabbath, that's a
tradition. The seventh day Sabbath,
that's a Bible rule. One man, two or
three wives, that's a tradition.
God gave a man to a woman. That's Bible
law. So we go by the Bible, not by
tradition. But our pioneers made great
contribution to the study of the Bible.
But in some points they were off.
In some points, yes, like not believing
in the Holy Spirit.
Solomon was dead wrong. Mhm.
Abs. Okay. Let me go to Matthew chapter
19.
Are you related to Solomon? Let's go to
Matthew 19.
Let's go to Ma I'll come to you. Let's
go to Matthew 19.
Let's read from verse three. Now, let's
read microscopically.
Do you have Matthew 19? Read with me.
The Pharisees also came unto him,
tempting him and saying unto him, Is it
lawful for a man to put away his wife?
Come on, for every cause. Read verse
four.
And he answered, "Have you not read that
he which made them when?"
>> Stop.
How far back does Jesus go to answer the
question?
>> Creation.
When God put Adam and Eve together at
creation, was it his will they divorced?
No, it still isn't his will. So Jesus
says, "Let's go back to the way it was
before sin caused problems."
Now Jesus said he made them male and
female and said for this cause shall a
man leave his father and mother and
shall cleave to his wife and they twin
shall be one flesh. What therefore God
hath put together let no man join
together let no man put us under. And
they say unto him why did Moses then
command to give a writing of divorcement
and to put her away? Read verse 8. He
said to them Moses because of the
hardness of your heart suffered you to
put away your wives but from the
beginning.
What is God saying? My desire is always
that you keep the standards set up
where? At the beginning. When was the
Sabbath set up? At the beginning.
Should we follow it today? Yes.
When was male headship set up? At the
beginning. Should we follow it today
despite what society says? Yes. I didn't
say male domination.
I said male headship.
They're not the same thing.
The headship of a man in a family must
be the headship of Christ over the
church. And Christ died for the church.
Christ didn't beat up the church.
>> Christ didn't run around in the church.
He had one woman. He's always had one,
the church. When she left him, he waited
for her to come back. Are you following
me? We must f
When she left him, the church would
leave Christ by go off in apostasy.
Under Solomon, the church went the
entire nation went into apostasy.
Go to Malachi chapter 2.
We have a modern Solomon. Malachi
chapter 2.
Malachi chapter 2.
Let's go to that verse and see the mind
of God. Do you have Malachi chapter 2?
>> All right. Tell me when you're in that
chapter.
>> You there? Read verse 16 and read
carefully.
For the Lord God of Israel saith that he
hateth what? Putting away. Now to answer
your question, you know the book of
Hosea. What do you know of Hosea?
He was married to a woman called what?
GMA. What was her profession?
>> Prostitute. God said marry her. Now I
would have to ask God a few questions,
but God said marry her. God wanted Hosea
to understand what he went through when
Israel went after other gods, he take
her back. Went after other gods, take
back it. But all the time, all the time.
And so Hosea went off with another man
and had a child. I said, Hosea, go get
her. Oh, that must have been tough.
Is one thing a man does not want to see
is his wife's stomach large with another
man's child. Are you following me? A man
can't take that. He'll kill you. And in
some countries, he'll get a medal for
killing you. God, go take her back. She
went off again. God said, "Go take her
back."
This is the way God is with us.
>> Mhm.
You see, Calvary preaches
reconciliation.
We serve a God who loves to fix broken
relationship. The fact that the Bible
allows divorce doesn't mean you have to
divorce.
It's the last option. You see staying
together is God's original will. Divorce
is the result of sin. What did Jesus
say? Moses because of the hardness of
it's like meat and vegetarianism.
Vegetarianism was given before there was
sin. Meat eating was allowed because of
sin. And Li says God allowed meat to
shorten people's lives because God
doesn't like sinners living long.
So one of the functions of meat is to
shorten your life.
But it's merciful because the longer you
live in sin, the more you suffer in the
judgment. So God is so nice. God said,
"Give them meat.
They die quickly and you don't have to
suffer that much." Are you following me?
So
when you
ah I see your faith is being tested
severely.
Yes. So yes, my brother, it's not easy.
You see, that's why we must have the
mind of Christ.
Because when a woman leaves you or man
leaves you, it hurts you to the core.
But your first question is it does it
hurt me? The question is, what's the
godly response? And the godly response
is get her back.
Yes, you have grounds. But didn't go God
have grounds to destroy Adam and Eve?
Yes. But he sacrificed that he might
save them. To function like that, you
need a change.
Because this is godly behavior in a
human being. Forgiveness and
reconciliation. The fact that divorce is
allowed does not mean you have to do it.
Mhm. Tough.
But divine standards are tough. Yes.
>> Which was
Uh-huh.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Huh.
>> Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Uh. Colossians 2:16.
Mhm. Let's go there. Let's go there.
Let's go there. Let's go there. Let's go
from verse 14 of 2 Colossians. No, not
second. Colossians 2. Let's go from
verse 14.
People use that all the time to defend
ignoring the Sabbath. And that verse is
not talking about not keep the Sabbath.
Let's go to Colossians 2:14.
Are you there? Let's pray again. Father,
as I deal with this troublesome passage,
well, some people try to twist it. Help
us to understand. I pray please in Jesus
name. Amen. Read for me. What does it
say?
Pause. Pause. Pause. Do you have my
version?
>> King James. Only King James people read.
God bless the others. Okay.
Okay.
We don't want you sounding like the
tower of babel. So only King James
people read. Okay. Read now. What does
that say?
>> And having
wiped out is not the King James version.
>> Coloss Colossians chapter 2
>> verse 14.
>> And having blotted it out. Yes. Uh-huh.
>> Mhm. Which was
>> he took it out of the way,
>> nailing it to the cross. Keep reading.
Verse 25. And having spoiled
principalities and powers, he made a
show of them openly, triumphing over
them in it. Now, which is Christ's
conquest in life and death. When he rose
from the dead, he conquered. Now, read
verse 16. But before you read 16, he
made a show of them openly. When a Roman
emperor conquered, he returned to Rome
carrying all his captives, some slaves
and animals or whatever else. He made a
parade of all that he conquered. Christ
conquered death, hell. So he's also
making a public parade exposing the
devil and hell and death the grave.
That's what 15 is telling us. Now read
verse 16. Let no man therefore judge you
in
>> me or in drink
or
which things are a
>> Now they are a shadow of things to come.
Now the Sabbath is not a shadow of
things to come. The sha the Sabbath is a
memorial of something past.
Are you following me? But even so, the
verse doesn't say don't keep the
Sabbath. The verse says don't let people
judge you.
It doesn't say don't keep. Let no one
judge you in meat or drink or respect
the holy day or the new moon or the
Sabbath days. That's fine.
If I observe the holy days, you don't
know if I'm a holy person or not. Let no
man judge you. But the verse does not
say, "Don't keep the Sabbath." If I were
to say, "Let no man judge you in your
clothes." Would you take them off?
Are you following me? Huh? Don't judge
people based on what you see them doing.
But the Sabbath is not a a a shadow of
anything to come. It is essentially a
memorial of something past, and that is
creation. And now it has spiritual
lessons. If anywhere being Christ is a
new creation, but a Sabbath is to
remember that God created heaven and it
is not a shadow of anything to come.
All right, my Yes, sister. Yes.
Go ahead. Just ask it.
Go ahead.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Read it.
You need your reading glasses. Someone
who does not read reading glasses.
Read second Corinthians 5:8.
Uh-huh.
>> Okay. Willing rather to be absent from
the body. Uh-huh. and to be present with
the what's the problem with that verse?
Does that verse say as soon as you're
absent from the body, you're present
with the Lord? It doesn't say that. It
said to be absent from the body and to
at some point you will be present with
the Lord. It is now the Okay, I'll let
you can have a seat, sister.
>> Okay, we have to study the Bible. How?
>> Here. Yes.
God bless you. Okay, I wasn't expecting
that. All right, it is here a little,
there a little, line upon line. Now
Paul, now all Bible writers are led by
whom? The Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit
is the spirit of truth. Paul cannot say
one thing in Corinthians and say
something else in in Thessalonians.
Let's go to 1 Thessalonians chapter 4.
Listen to the same apostle Paul.
Let's read verse 16.
For the Lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout, with a voice of the
archangel, and with the trump of God,
and the dead in Christ shall rise first.
So where are the dead in Christ? In the
grave. That's Paul. Are you following
me? Go to 1 Corinthians 15.
Read verse 21.
Since by man came death, come on. By man
also came the
>> Mhm. Now, who's that man that brought
resurre Jesus Christ talks about
resurrection from the dead.
Read from verse 17 of uh 1 Corinthians
15. Read 17.
If Christ be not, keep reading, faith is
vain, you are still in your So Paul is
saying Christ rose from the dead. Verse
18,
then also all they that sleep in are.
>> Yes, we're still in the grave. They
asleep in Christ. Verse 19.
If in this life only we have hope in
where have all men most. Now verse 20.
Now is Christ risen
>> and become the first fruits that slept.
>> So whatever whatever 2 Corinthians 5:8
may say, it cannot contradict.
Here's a Bible rule you must follow.
It's recommended. Never use an verse to
explain a clear verse. You use a clear
verse to try to explain an verse. 2
Corinthians 5:8 is not as clear as the
Lord himself shall descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of the
archangel trump of God and the dead in
there's nothing controversial. There's
controversy over 2 Corinthians 5'8. So
the question is which one do I trust?
The clear verse both are trustworthy but
one is more easily grasped than the
other. When you read Paul 1 Corinthians
15:17-21,
uh 1 Thessalonians 4:16-17, it is very
very obvious that the dead are asleep
and one day Christ shall raise them. But
also with the state of the dead, here is
another Bible rule to follow. It is
called the law of first mention, which
means when studying any Bible subject,
begin where that subject first enters
the Bible.
If you're studying grace, where would
you start?
Noah.
Noah. Genesis chapter 6:8. But Noah
found grace. You don't start Ephesians
2:8. By grace I saved through faith.
Eventually you get there. But you begin
Genesis 2 verse 8. If you wanted to
study righteousness by faith, where do
you begin? Genesis. And the Lord God and
unto Adam also unto his wife did the
Lord God make coats of skins and clothe
them.
If you wanted to study you the second
coming you don't start in Matthew 24 you
go to Genesis 3:15. And I will put
enmity between the woman between thy
seed her seed it shall bruise thy head.
That is connected to the second coming.
So the law of first mention says go
where something first enters the Bible.
Let's see where the state of the dead
first enters the Bible.
Genesis 2:7. You must have heard me
before. Genesis 2:7. And the Lord God
did what? For man of the dust of the
ground. This is very serious. Breathe
into his nostrils the breath of life.
Man became a living soul. In Genesis 3:1
19, God says you go back
to where you came from.
That's why the Bible says 1 Corinthians
15, the first man is of the the last the
first man is of the earth earthy. The
last man is a Lord from heaven. He's of
the earth, earthy. The principle of God
is you go back to where you came from.
That's the dust. By the way, it also
applies to animals. Ecclesiastes
3:19-31. They all go to the same place.
All of the dust all go to dust. Again,
that's clear as day.
That's where you you don't start in Luke
16. The Lazarus and the rich man. You
don't start there at all. You start in
Genesis 2 and 3. That's where you
establish a foundation. Now, when you've
got the foundation, that's where you
stand to look at any other verse because
no other verse can take you off that
foundation.
God told Adam and Eve, well, he told
Adam, Genesis 21:16:17, "And the Lord
God commanded the man, saying, of every
tree of the garden, thou mayest freely
eat, but of the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil, thou shalt not eat of it.
For in the day thou eatest thereof? Thou
shalt surely die. That's a foundation
stone for what is the punishment for
sin? Death. Nothing else in the Bible
can change that.
It gives you stand on that verse and
study right through. The foundation
doesn't change as you add to the house
of truth.
Get to the foundation.
The problem with many of these churches,
they start Let's go to go to 1 Timothy
chapter 4. Let me show you what I mean.
1 Timothy chapter 4.
Let's read from verse one.
Now the spirit speaketh expressly that
in the latter time some shall depart
from the faith. Keep reading. Giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of devil. Pause. Any error is a doctrine
of the devil.
You didn't hear me. Anything opposed to
the truth of God is a doctrine of the
devil.
I don't want to hurt any feelings, but
if you regard Tuesday as the Sabbath,
that is a doctrine of the devil.
Forbidding to marry and commanding to
abstain from meat, which God hath
created to be received of them that
believe and know the truth. Now read
verse four for me. For every creature of
God is good, and nothing to be refused
if it be received with thanksgiving, for
it's sanctified by the word of God and
prayer. Now, a lot of Sunday churches
use that verse to say, "I can eat
anything."
But let's go back to verse three. Read
it carefully. Read it for me.
>> Forbidding to marry and commanding to
abstain from meat which God hath
created, uh-huh. To be received
>> with thanksgiving.
>> Ah, of whom? Them that believe, not the
whole world.
Paul is referring to a certain group of
people and the meats that are suitable
for them. Now those are the meats in
mind when he writes every creature of
God is good for food that he made for
those who believe
in verse three not for everybody
which God hath created to be received
with thanksgiving of those that believe
and know the truth.
Now, all those that animals God made for
the believers, they're good if they're
see with thanksgiving. The Bible doesn't
say rats and snakes and bats are good
for food. That's not what that text is
saying. Because the same people who try
to make that text say that anything is
good, they do not eat cockroaches. Are
you following me? They do not eat slugs.
They do not eat spiders. The people who
say when you die, you go straight to
heaven, they don't want to die. Are you
with me?
Know the word of God for yourself. Now
go to Genesis chapter 7.
Genesis 7.
Let's read from verse one
of Genesis 7.
And the Lord said unto Noah, "Come thou
and all thy house into the ark. For thee
have I seen righteous before me in this
generation." Now very carefully read
verse two. Of every clean beast thou
shalt take to thee by sevens the male
and his female. Of beasts that are not
clean by two the male and his female. Of
fouls also of the air by sevens the male
and the female to keep seed alive upon
the face of all the earth. Stop. Have
you observed some foods in that verse?
Even before the flood
they were clean.
This is not a Levitical thing. Are you
with me?
This happened before the flood came
clean. Now God knew after the flood that
the people have to eat. He wants more
clean alive than unclean. So he take
seven pairs of clean, two pairs of
unclean because all vegetation
destroyed. God gives them permission to
eat meat. Are you following me? But
there were clean and unclean foods just
before the flood came. which means that
was the case many many years before the
flood.
Go to Genesis 4. Long before the flood.
Genesis 4.
Let's read from verse
19 of Genesis 4.
Are you there? Read with me. What does
it say? And Lamech took unto him two
wives. The name of the one was name the
other Zilla. Keep reading. And she bear
>> Jeel. He was the
>> father of
>> the father of what?
>> And
ah why were they keeping the cattle?
They must have been eating meat even
before God gave permission. Are you with
me? The father of such as dwelling tents
and have cattle. Stay in Genesis 4, but
let's go to verse one.
Let's read. And Adam knew Eve his wife.
And she conceived and bare Cain and
said, "I have gotten a man from the
Lord." And she again bare his brother
Abel. Now carefully, Abel was a keeper
of sheep. Cain was a tiller. One was a
farmer, one was whatever you call people
who keep sheep. I heard that. Now, did
he eat the animals? I don't know. But he
kept them. Now, he could have been the
only one keeping sheep. So keeping
animals was a long long tradition which
began after sin.
So we have clean and unclean hundreds of
years before the Israelites showed up in
the wilderness.
So God wants us to know after sin. Even
before sin, there were fruits that you
could eat and fruits you couldn't eat.
Are you with me? Do not eat the fruit of
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil. Not because the fruit was bad.
Because God said, "Don't eat it. If you
eat it, you'll die."
We must be careful not to build a
theology on one isolated text. We must
be careful not to start our study way in
the Bible and ignore the foundation.
All right. Next question. Make it easy.
Yes.
>> As someone who's not yet asked a
question. Not yet. Not yet. I'll come
back to you. You've had one. You've had
one. Yes, my good sister.
Mhm.
Look, when you read the whole verse
Okay. Right. Now you're saying, "Will
there be death in the new world?" No.
You've got to study here a little there
a little. In the new world, there is no
death. What you need to understand
prophecies have two layers of meaning.
At times
Isaiah is looking forward to the time
when the Israelites would return to
their own homeland. When Isaiah is
prophesying the Israelites were
scattered abroad, particularly the
northern kingdom. They had been
conquered by the Assyrians in 7:21 BC.
The southern kingdom 586 by
Nebuchadnezzar. Isaiah is pointing to
the time when God would bring his people
back from captivity and they live in
their own land and life would be
entirely different. But that also has a
higher meaning. There is a coming a day
when God's people worldwide will be
taken to another land where they're free
from the harassment and the problems of
sin. And so yes, in the when they return
to their own land, the child will live
to this and this and this whatever and
die at a good old age. But in the new
world, which is the higher level of
interpretation, there will be no death
at all at all. So that verse does not
say there will be death in the new
world. is the earthly and then there's
the heavenly.
All right. Yes, my brother, you jumped
up with a lot of energy. What's the
question?
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
Well, of course we do.
Okay, let let's get let let me pray
again for that. Father,
speak to me I pray as I deal with this
absolutely important question. In Jesus
name I pray. Amen. The question is, is
Jesus as much God as the father? The
answer is yes. Now go to Isaiah 9. If
you're not sure who Jesus is, your
salvation is in jeopardy. Can or the
Holy Spirit for that matter. Isaiah 9.
Let's read from verse six.
Because only God can save you. If Jesus
is less than God, he cannot save you. Do
you have Isaiah 9? Reading verse 6. Read
for me. For unto us a child is born. Who
is that? Jesus. Unto us a son is given.
And the government shall be upon his
shoulder. Now carefully and his name
shall be come on wonderful counselor.
Stop the mighty God.
The mighty God. Now go to Hebrews
chapter 1.
Hebrews 1.
You know you should pray while I'm
answering these questions. Ask God put
his word. This is very very serious.
This questions 1.
Let me set it up for you. In Hebrews
chapter 1, the father is talking to the
son.
The father is making a difference
between angels and the son. Hebrews
chapter 1 stresses the divinity of
Christ. Hebrews chapter 2, the humanity
of Christ. Now let's go to uh verse 10.
Let's go from verse 8 of Hebrews 1. Keep
in mind this is the father speaking.
Nobody argues with the father. They
argue with Jesus. They argue the holy
spirit. They do not argue with the
father. Read with me. Thy throne.
Stop.
What does the father call Jesus? Oh god.
Thy throne oh god is for ever and ever.
A scepter of righteousness is the
scepter of thy kingdom. Now you tell me
who has a kingdom.
Normally who has a kingdom? A king. What
is a scepter?
It's a a symbol of power. You know
African leaders like to carry them. A
symbol of power. Um some carry something
to brush off the flies or whatever else.
I think it was uh is it um Moy used to
carry some kind of stick. Okay. All
right. Jesus's scepter is a scepter of
righteousness now. But the father called
him God. Read verse 9. Thou hast loved
righteousness and hated iniquity. Go to
verse 10 and read carefully. And thou
Lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth. Who is
speaking?
What does he say about Jesus in verse
10?
He calls him Lord. He calls him God in
verse 8. He calls him Lord in verse 10.
But what is he in verse 10 based on what
the father said?
He's the creator.
The father acknowledged. He says, "And
thou lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and the heavens
are the work of thy hands." Now,
in the beginning, God created the heaven
and the earth. Who did creation? Jesus
Christ. God created. Now, go to verse
11. They shall perish.
Stop. What is the they that shall
perish?
The heaven and the earth mentioned in
verse 10. Why will they perish? Because
of sin. So God has to make new heaven
earth. Now they shall perish. But thou
now we have opposites.
Something that perishes is what?
Temporary.
But thou remainest. Now what does that
mean?
>> Eternal. The father's contrasting. This
heaven and earth must go. You don't. And
they all shall wax old asth a garment
and as a vesture shalt thou fold them up
and they shall be changed. Read the next
words. But thou art the same and thy
years shall not fail. What does that
mean?
Thy years shall not fail. What's that?
Eternal. Now we have just found out the
father said Jesus created. Now go to
Psalm 90, the 90th Psalm. By the way,
that psalm was written by Moses. Psalm
90 was written by Moses. Beautiful
psalm. Let's go to Psalm 90.
Putting verse together.
You have Psalm 90.
Reading from verse one. Lord, thou hast
been our dwelling place in all
generations before the mountains are
brought forth. Orever thou hast formed
the earth and the world even from
everlasting to everlasting. Come on,
finish it. Thou art God. Now who formed
the earth? Jesus. Who told us that? The
father.
The Bible says he has been there from
everlasting
to everlasting. Now go to Hebrews 9.
Hebrews 9.
You have Hebrews 9.
Read from verse 13.
For if the blood of bulls and goats and
the ashes of heaven sprinkling the
sanctified to the purifying of the
flesh, how much more shall the blood of
Christ? Verse 14. Read with me now. Who
through the Now what is the eternal
spirit?
The Holy Spirit. What do you understand
by the eternal spirit?
He's always been there.
Eternal means forever. The Bible calls
the Holy Spirit the eternal spirit.
Only a God, only a divine being can be
eternal.
No one questions the father. That's not
the problem. We question Jesus.
Let me tell you something.
There's father, son, holy spirit. Before
sin, the next most powerful being was
whom?
Lucifer.
Are you following me? The next most
powerful being was Lucifer. Let me say
it again. Father, Son, Holy Spirit. Now
listen to Ellen White. Bible comies
volume 1, page 341, paragraph 1. No,
paragraph 1. Yes. Bible uh testimonies
volume 1, 341, paragraph 1.
God alone can limit the power of Satan.
Now, testimonies volume 5, page 448,
paragraph 2. Jesus can limit the power
of Satan. Evangelism 617, paragraph 2.
The prince of the power of evil can only
be held in check by the power of God in
the third person of the Godhead, the
Holy Spirit. What is she saying? Only
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit can control
Satan.
You see, go to Daniel 10.
This is more important than you imagine.
I'll be here till 10:00 tonight
defending Jesus.
>> And I'm willing to do it
because if Jesus is not God, you are in
trouble. He cannot save you.
You have had Daniel 10. Now Daniel verse
three says Daniel was praying three
weeks. He wants to understand some
things that God showed him in vision. As
a matter of fact, God told Gabriel make
this man to understand the vision.
Daniel 8:16. It was so heavy. Now
Gabriel comes to Daniel after he had
fasted 3 weeks. Let's read from verse
12. And he said unto me what?
Fear not Daniel for from the first day
that thou deset thine heart to
understand and to chasten thyself before
thy God. Thy prayer was heard. Pause.
Let me digress.
Daniel prayed three weeks. When did God
hear the prayer? The very first day. But
God didn't answer the very first day.
Leave the answer to God. Are you with
me?
Thy prayer was heard and I am come.
Finish verse 12.
But I
Yes. Now read verse 13. But the prince
of the kingdom of Persia withstood me
one. Now that is a symbol of Satan. Now
who is speaking? Gabriel. Now Desire of
Ages page 693 paragraph 3. The mighty
angel who stands in God's presence
occupying the position from which
Lucifer fell came to the side of Christ
Gabriel took Lucifer's place. Gabriel is
the highest angel in heaven. But Satan
held him up
for 21 days.
Finish verse 13. But lo, Michael, one of
the chief angels came to chief princes
came to no
in heaven.
The father, the son, the holy spirit.
Then Gabriel.
Gabriel needed help to deal with Satan.
That help had to be from a being who is
divine.
Elite tells us in testimonies volume 1,
page 342, paragraph 1, all should
understand that Satan was once an
exalted angel. His rebellion shut him
out of heaven but did not destroy his
powers.
All the power he had before he sinned,
he took with him. Gabriel could not get
past him.
It took a divine being to break that
impass.
Now the only person who can save you
from Satan is someone who is God.
Someone less than God can only hope for
a draw in a battle with Satan. No one is
saved because of a draw. Someone has to
win. Jesus Christ is fully God. He is
fully divine as is the eternal spirit
because only a divine being can be
eternal. The only reason why Jesus gives
us eternal life is because he has it to
give.
No angel can give you eternal life
because he doesn't have it.
Angels depend on God for life. Jesus
said, "I am life."
Now go to Romans chapter 8.
Romans chapter 8. Read from verse one.
Say amen when you're there.
There's therefore now no condemnation to
them which are in Christ Jesus, who walk
not after the flesh, but after the
spirit. For the law of the spirit of
life.
The spirit is called the spirit of life.
The very life that Christ says, I'm the
life. The spirit is eternal. The spirit
is the spirit of life. Let me tell you
something else. Read John 14:6.
Jesus saith unto him.
You're not there yet.
I am the way, the truth, and the life.
Now Jesus says, I'm the truth.
Go to first John chapter 5, read verse
6. 1 John 5, read verse 6.
1 John chapter 5. Yes.
Let's read verse six. This is he that
came by water and blood. Even Jesus not
by water only, but by water and blood.
Now carefully finish the verse.
That beareth witness. Why? Because the
spirit is truth. Jesus says I am truth.
The spirit says I am truth.
Go to Deuteronomy chapter 32.
Deuteronomy 32.
You have it, my good people. Read verse
four. For he is the rock. His work is
perfect. Come on.
All his ways are judgment. A god of
truth and without it. So we have the
father is truth. Come on. The son is
truth. The holy spirit is truth. But
Jesus says I am the way,
the truth, and the life. We discovered
in um Romans 8:2 that the spirit is the
spirit of life.
Jesus is the way. Walk in the spirit.
You shall not fulfill the lust of the
flesh. The spirit is also the way. So
whatever Jesus is, the truth, the life,
the way, the spirit is the truth, the
life, the way, the father is the same.
Now go to John chapter 5, chapter 10,
sorry, chapter 10.
John 10.
Read verse 30. Very simple, short verse.
I and my father are one.
Now we go to John five.
Remember the man who had been sick 30
and 8 years at the pool of the remember
that fellow. Jesus healed him. Let's
read from verse 14 of John 5. When you
found it, tell me. Afterward Jesus
findeth him in the temple and said unto
him, "Behold, thou art made whole. Sin
no more, lest the worst thing come unto
thee. The man departed and told the Jews
that it was Jesus which had made him
whole. And therefore did the Jews
persecute Jesus and sought to slay him
because he done these things on the
Sabbath day. Now listen carefully to the
next verse. But Jesus answered them
what? My father worketh hitherto and I
work. Stop. My father worketh it I work.
Now read the next verse. Therefore, the
Jews sought the mortu because he not
only had broken the Sabbath but said
also God was his father making himself
they understood that he said I am equal
that's why they tried to kill him
because that's blasphemy
they understood he was saying I'm equal
with the father and they tried to kill
him
go to John chapter
John 10.
Let's read from verse 30 again
and read nice and clear. Read for me. I
and my father are one. Keep reading.
Now why? Now the Jews did what?
They took up stones.
They did what?
Ah, I'm looking for the word again. What
does that tell you? They've done it
before because Jesus kept saying in many
ways what I am just like my father. So
they took up stones again to stone him.
Keep reading. Jesus answered them what
for a good work uh many good works have
I show thee of my father. For which of
them do you ston me? Listen to the Jews.
For a good work come on we stone thee
not. But for blasphemy and that because
thou being a man make m make m make m
make m make m make m make m make m make
m make mst thyself. They understood he
was saying I am equal with my father. So
they tried to kill him. This was
blasphemy. But the Bible says they took
stones again. Jesus was always trying to
get them to understand I am equal with
the father. I'm human but I'm also
divine.
And they couldn't take it. They tried to
kill him. You must be willing to die for
the truth.
Jesus Christ is God the Father, God the
Son, God the Holy Spirit. Now go to
Matthew 12 so you can understand why
you've got to be careful what you say
about the Holy Spirit. Are you following
me? Matthew 12, read from verse 31.
And then we bring this to an end.
Temperance in all things, even in
question and answer.
Do you have Matthew 12
verse 31? Are you there?
>> Let me pray. Father, we're on the Holy
Spirit now. Please guide my mind and all
of us I pray in Jesus name. Amen. Verse
31. Therefore, wherefore I say unto you,
all manner of sin and blasphemy, come
on, shall be forgiven unto men, but the
blasphemy against the Holy Ghost shall
not be for now listen to me. Do not
blaspheme the Holy Ghost.
Next verse.
And whosoever shall speak a word against
the it shall be forgiven him. Talk
against Jesus forgiven you. But whoso
speaketh against the Holy Ghost, you
finish it. It shall not be forgiven him.
Not in this world, not in the world to
come. Do not speak irresponsibly about
the Holy Spirit.
Now go to Romans 8.
Romans 8.
Let's read verse 9.
But you're not in the flesh, if so be
that the spirit of God dwell in you. Now
if any man have not the spirit of
Christ, he's none of his.
You speak against the spirit and he
leaves you.
You don't belong to God. You have to
have the spirit. The presence of the
spirit in you is the marker. This is a
child of God.
Yes, sister.
You're having what?
Yes.
>> Uh-huh.
You have to train your mind.
Anytime you drift, bring the mind back.
Apologize to God. Bring the mind back. A
mind is like a child. It must be
trained.
A wondering mind wonders because it has
been allowed to wonder.
Bring it back. Bring it back. Bring it
back. And you'll find after a while you
can focus on the God you're praying to.
Just bring it back. Don't just say, "Ah,
I wanded away." Bring it back.
Go to Isaiah 26.
You know the first verse three.
Isaiah 26:3. Tell me what that says.
Thou shalt keep him in whose mind is it
doesn't drift. Stay on God. Not only in
prayer in everything you do. If you just
want to keep your mind on God when
you're praying, you miss a lot of
opportunities to keep the mind on God.
Your mind should be on God when you
work. Whatsoever thy hand findeth to do,
do it with thine might. That's a
biblical principle. Your mind should be
on God when you're playing. Your mind
should be on God when you whatever. When
you do that, then it's easy for the mind
to stay on God. But if your mind is only
on God when you pray, but something else
most of the day, well, you've got a
problem.
Somebody else.
Yes. My sister in white representing the
righteousness of Christ. Yes. Okay.
Yes.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Mhm.
Okay. Sister, you're asking me to get
killed. Okay.
Ah, I thought you liked me. Okay.
I'm I'm serious.
Okay, go with me to Exodus. No, Genesis
35.
I was hoping no one would ask them.
I hoped in vain.
Genesis 35. Let's read verse from verse
one. Now, let me set it up. In Genesis
34, a terrible crime has been committed
by two sons of Jacob. Who are the two
sons? Simeon and Levi. Their sister was
raped
by a prince of some nearby city. The two
sons went to the prince and said, "Look,
now when you have 12 boys in a family,
one girl, those boys protect that girl."
You following me? Jacob had 13 children,
12 boys, one girl, and she was number 11
in the line. Then Joseph and Benjamin.
They went to the prince and said, "Look,
you defiled our sister.
You have to marry her." The guy said,
"Yes, I'll marry you." Because he liked
her, but he still raped her. The boy
said, "Look, she cannot marry
uncircumcised people." The prince said,
"We'll get circumcised."
So,
they all got circumcised on one day.
But a couple days later, when they
couldn't move, the men understand what
I'm talking about.
Simeon and Levi with their servants came
into the city with their swords and
killed all the men. Mass murder,
enslaved all the women, all the girls,
took all the cattle outside the city and
took off.
When Jacob heard that, Jacob said, "Oh,
we're just a few people. all the other
cities will come together to avenge this
crime.
A terrible spiritual crisis. Now they
have to rebound from that. Now God is
telling Jacob what to do. Let's go to
verse one of chapter 35. That's the
background. And and read for me what
does it say? And God said unto Jacob,
arise, go up to Bethl and dwell there.
Keep reading. and make there an altar
unto God that appeared unto thee when
thou fledest from the face of J Esau thy
brother. God told Jacob, "Leave the
area."
Move.
Verse two. And Jacob said unto his unto
all that were with him, "Put away the
false gods that are in your hand." Keep
reading.
And change your garments and
and do what? And be clean. Verse three.
and let us arise and go up to Bethl, and
I will make an altar unto God that was
with me in the way which I came,
answered the day of my distress, and was
with me in the way which I went. Now,
let's read verse two again and find out
what did Jacob tell his household to do.
Itemize for me.
Put away the false gods. Number one.
Number two,
>> be clean. Number three, change your
garments. Okay? Put away the false gods.
be clean.
Let's see what they did in obedience.
Verse four.
And they gave Jacob all the
>> Come on. All the
That's right in the hand. And the
>> Yes.
Now, does verse two call for earrings to
be given up? No. But they understood
that part of being clean meant get rid
of that stuff. Are you following me?
They gave him all that stuff. Now finish
verse four. And Jacob hit them under the
oak which was by Sheckchum. What does
that mean?
Go to Matthew 25.
Matthew 25.
Let's read from verse 14.
Familiar story. Read with me. And the
kingdom of heaven is like unto
traveling into far country who called
his own servants and did what?
>> His goods.
And to another two, to another one. To
every man according to his several
ability. and straightway took his
journey. Now next verse. Then he which
had received the five, come on, went and
traded with the same and made them other
five. And likewise he that had received
the two, he also gained two. Now
carefully
read verse 18.
Uh-huh.
What did he do?
>> He dig in the earth and buried it. What
does that mean?
The one who had five, what did he do?
He used it. Oh, who said that? Nice
person. He used it. He used it. The one
who had two, what did he do? He used it.
The one who had one, what did he do? He
didn't use it. How was that expressed?
He bettered it. Now go back to Genesis
35.
Read verse four.
And he gave unto Jacob all the strange
gods. Uh-huh. Earrings. We say the ear
is. Uh-huh.
And hid them under the He buried them.
What does that mean? Don't use them. No.
Don't use them anymore. He buried them.
Now, this was spiritual preparation to
be cleansed from a terrible crime.
Even though only two brothers had
committed murder, the entire family was
guilty in a certain sense.
And so God says, you've got to go
through a spiritual renewal.
Here's what you do. Now, let's look at
another crisis. Go to Exodus 32.
Exodus 32. Another spiritual crisis. And
God is putting his people through
another cleansing experience. Exodus 32.
What happened in that chapter?
The worship of the golden calf. Let's go
to verse 7 of chapter 32. We know they
worshiped the golden calf. Verse six,
the people sat down to eat and drink and
rose up to play. Okay, verse seven. What
does seven say? And the Lord said unto
Moses, what
>> go get thee down for thy people which
thou
>> hath corrupted themselves. Now God is
complaining. Read verse 10. And what
does God say? Now therefore let me alone
that my wrath may wax hot against them
that I may consume them and I will make
of thee a great name. God wants to
destroy them. Why? For worshiping a
golden calf. Now go to verse 30. Chapter
33.
Chapter 33.
Are you there? If you have my version,
read verse one.
God unto Moses,
>> depart.
Now stop. What did God tell Jacob?
Depart. Go up somewhere else. What did
God tell Moses? Mhm. Each time they're
departing from the sight of a spiritual
crisis, and they have to be cleansed.
Now, let's read verse four.
When the people heard these evil
tactics, the people and they what?
No man did put on his ornament because
God said I'm about to destroy you. Read
verse five. Because the Lord
had said
stiff naked people. Mhm. I will come
into the midst of them and consume them.
Keep reading.
>> Therefore now put off
that I may know. Yes. Put off all that
stuff you have. Now read verse six. And
the people stripped themselves. What
does strip mean? They took off
everything
by and Bible commenters tell you there's
no evidence they ever put them back on.
We're looking at two spiritual crises.
And as a part of cleansing and recovery,
God told them, "Take all that off.
Take it off." Now go to Genesis chapter
2.
Genesis 2.
Read verse 25.
They were both naked, the man and his
wife, and were not ashamed. Now, when
you say they were naked, what did they
have on them?
>> Nothing. What did they have in their
ears? Nothing. On their wrists, their
ankles, their noses, nothing.
Now, God had made a creature before who
had a lot of stuff.
Go to Ezekiel 28.
Ezekiel 28.
Let's read from verse uh
13.
This is biographical information about
Lucifer.
He was a beautiful creature. I mean just
with all the light of God bouncing off
him was tremendous sight to see him fly
through heaven. Do you have Ezekiel 28?
Let me pray. Father, as I continue,
please instruct my mind. I ask in Jesus
name. Amen. Thou hast been in Eden.
Verse 13, are you with me? The garden of
God. Every precious stone was thy
covering. The sardius, the topaz, the
diamond. Keep reading. The barrel, the
the jasper, come on. The sapphire, the
emerald, the carbuncle, and gold. Now he
was covered in these things.
How many stones mentioned there? 10.
Mhm. 10. By the way, the high priest had
13.
If you read Exodus 28:17 to20, the high
priest had 13. Lucifer had 10 of those
stones. So Lucifer looked a lot like
Jesus. Because Jesus the high priest,
you see he looked a lot like Jesus.
But now keep reading. The workmanship of
thy tabs and thy pipes was prepared in
thee in the day when thou was created.
God gave Lucifer a specially constructed
voice.
But read verse 17 now.
Thy heart was lifted up in thee because
of thy th corrupted by wisdom by reason
of thy. His outward beauty became a
problem.
He was very beautiful on the outside but
became corrupt on the inside because he
focused on the out. Now let me tell you
something else. Go back to Genesis
then I'll let you go on this point so I
don't get any more hard questions. Let's
go to Genesis chapter 3.
Are you there? Now let's read from verse
5.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food, and that it was pleasant
to the eyes on the tree to be desired to
make one wise, she took of the fruit
thereof, and did eat, and gave also unto
her husband with her, and he did eat.
And the eyes of them both were opened,
and they knew that they were naked. You
finish the verse. And they sowed fig
leaves together, and made themselves
Abra. Now, were they naked in verse 25
of chapter 2?
>> Read it for me.
And they were both naked. The man and
his wife were not ashamed. They had no
problem with the fact that there was
nothing on them. The light surrounded by
light, but nothing on the ears and no
not no problem.
Now they naked in chapter 3. They've got
a problem because of sin. Now they're
trying to do something about the
nakedness. They sewed fig leaves
together and made them. Now the fig leaf
aprons covered where? The inside or the
outside? The outside. Listen to me
carefully. The very first thing the
Bible records that a human being made
with the aprons
to cover and improve and beautify the
outside.
From then until now, we put more
emphasis on beautifying the outside than
the inside.
The very first thing human beings ever
made was something to beautify the
outside.
When God made ears, he put an opening
right here. He didn't put one here.
Now, here's a baby girl that's born.
What is your biblical reason for boring
a hole in the child's ear? Tell me.
None.
I'll tell you something about jewelry
and and adornment.
When the ancients made their idols, they
adorned their idols. Are you following
me? They adorn them. Go to Jeremiah 10
quickly. You said, "Yeah, but you don't
believe me." Go to Jeremiah 10.
Read from verse three.
Jeremiah 10. Reading from verse three.
Are you there? Read with me. For the
custom of the people are vain. For one
cutth a tree out of the forest, the work
of the hand of the workman with the axe.
Now keep reading. They
>> they do what?
>> They deck it with silver. And what does
deck mean?
>> Decorate. Now go to Revelation 17.
Read verse four of re. Mr. cameraman, am
I causing a problem by moving a little
bit? Okay. All right. Okay. Do you have
Revelation 17?
Read verse four. And a woman was arrayed
in purple and scarlet color and decked
with gold and now she was decked. Now we
go back to Jeremiah 10 verse4. They deck
it. What does deck mean? Covered all.
Yes. None of that stuff. Now
those who made idols wanted to look like
them. Are you following me? So they
covered themselves the same way. They
wanted to look like them
covered themselves.
Jewelry
was never God's will for his people.
I was a
I was in a certain country on the face
of the earth. Talking to a group of
young people and I was talking on 1
Corinthians 10:31. Whether therefore you
eat or drink or whatsoever you do, do
all to the glory of God. Why am I boring
a hole in my nose? Why am I painting a
tattoo on my whatever? Do all to the
glory of God.
When I was finished, the young people
left. The next morning, I was doing
onetoone counseling. A young lady came
to me. Now, the day before, she had a
big hairstyle. A lot of, you know, the
weaves and connections, whatever else,
and large thing.
It was gone. The very next day, I didn't
recognize her. She said, "Do you
recognize me?" I said, "No." She said,
"I am the young lady who's in front." I
said, "Oh, what happened?" She said,
"Well,"
she said, "After listening to that
present, I realize I did that for my
glory, not for God." She took it off.
She wrote me a few months later. She
wants to be a medical missionary. I was
preaching in another country, week of
prayer. We were having a baptism at the
end. And all week this guy came with a
lot of, you know what dreadlocks are?
that big thing all hanging down all over
the place and all artificial
and uh well I didn't say anything
the morning of baptism because he chose
to be baptized he stepped away and went
to the back of the church and came back
and it was gone
he just got it all out
there's a I have a friend is in
California he used to be a rapper now an
Adventist he told me when he was a
rapper
his god was his hair.
He had all this when he came to Christ,
he just
am trying to say the principle of the
glory of God must apply to everything we
do. Here's a principle of the world
because I want to. That's the principle
of the world because I want to. I was in
South Africa a few years ago in a
restaurant, myself and a young man and a
waitress came to us and she had a piece
of metal cut through her nose
and I said, "Sister, may I ask her
questions?" Yeah. Yeah. What? Why do you
have that thing in your nose? She said,
"Because I want to."
And she spoke for the whole world,
almost the whole world. Why do you
Because I want to.
Why is your whole left arm covered in
tattoos? because I want to.
They're in church. This question should
be because it glorifies God. Are you
following me? God has given us a
principle to the glory of God.
This is not symbolic.
By the way, it applies to the marital
bedroom.
I won't say anything else.
To the glory of God. You know why? Go to
Isaiah 43:7.
Then I'm done.
Isaiah 43:7. Why should everything be
done for the glory of God? Do you have
Isaiah 43:7? Read that for me. What does
that say? Even everyone that is called
by my name. For I have created him. Why?
For my glory, not his.
which means you're not on this earth for
you. I am on this earth for God. And so
I think of him first.
All right. It's about 5:00 and I am
tired. Na is that it?
And all things have to come to an end
because talking gets you tired. Let me
urge you as your brother in Christ,
study the word of God.
Give me 10 more minutes. Say yes.
>> All right. Okay. Go to Acts chapter 8.
Go to the book of Acts, chapter 8. I'm
I'm going to stress the importance of
studying the word of God and not always
asking people, "Tell me, tell me, tell
me." Go to the book of Acts, chapter 8.
Now, what is well known in that chapter?
the story of the Ethiopian unic. All
right, read verse 26 for me.
And the angel of the Lord said what?
Arise and do what?
>> Go to the south.
He told him the way that the way that
goeth to what?
>> Yes, you go to the angel told him take
this route. Now read verse 29.
And the spirit said,
>> "Go in there and join thyself."
>> So we have two heavenly beings involved.
The angel told Philillip, "Go this way."
Why did the angel tell him, "Go this
way?" The angel knew the Ethiopian unic
was parked at the side of the road
trying to understand the scroll of
Isaiah. Of course, the Holy Spirit
guides the angels. Now the spirit told
Philip, "Now you go to the So we have
spirit and angel involved in a Bible
study.
Are you with me now? Go to Daniel
chapter 8.
Daniel 8,
brother Daniel. Faithful young man,
faithful old man, too.
Daniel 8. Do you have that?
Let's read verse 14 to 16. And he said
unto me, unto 2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed. By the way, Elise said, "This
is the most important verse for
Adventist theology." And it came to
pass, verse 15, "When I, even I, Daniel,
had seen the vision and sought for the
meaning, then they stood, behold, they
stood before me as the appearance of a
man." It was an angel. It was Gabriel.
And I heard a man's voice between the
banks of Uli, which called and said,
"What? Gabriel, come on. Make this man."
Now, what does God tell the angel?
Help him. In Bible study, angels are
commissioned to help us.
The spirit is the spirit of truth.
So we have the spirit of truth.
We have angels both sent by the father.
Bible study is fellowship with father,
son, holy spirit, and angels. Amen.
>> When you tell me study for me, you're
telling me go enjoy their fellowship for
me.
Try to study for yourself. Now, of
course, you'll come across some
challenging passages. God understands
that. That's why he gives people the
gift of teaching. But you have to try.
Even if you do not understand, just by
trying, something changes in your mind.
Here's how I always illustrate it.
There's something called you see this
desk is heavy. If I try to lift it and
it doesn't move but if I keep trying my
muscle changes the desk doesn't move but
something happens to the structure. It
becomes stronger. But this hasn't moved.
So don't just say it's a hard text and
you go to the supermarket and buy some
ice cream. You try
try apply the muscles of your mind and
that mind muscle will grow. Never bypass
Bible study and tell someone what does
it mean? What does it mean? Make an
effort for yourself
because even if you don't grasp it, the
very fact that you tried creates a
change in your mind.
May the Lord bless you. Put a double
blessing on your children.
Read this. Read the words of Ellen
White. Please read her writings. She
herself tells us those who study the
testimonies will not be deceived in the
last days.
>> They will not be deceived. But she also
prophesied that the devil will work
among some of us to undermine her
writings. And we see that throughout the
church. Don't be among that crowd.
Let's stand and pray.
Heads bowed, eyes closed. Our Father in
heaven, we thank you for your love.
We thank you for your word. You've told
us in second Peter chapter 3:9, "The
Lord is not willing that any should
perish." If that's the case, dear God,
you must make the gospel so simple that
anyone can understand because most
people are not highly educated. But give
us the love for the word that we may
study it to God that we may say like
Job, I have esteemed the words of his
mouth more than my necessary food.
Because that word will change us,
Father. It will cleanse us. It will
strengthen us. And it is defense against
the devil. Bless every family, every
individual, those who still need to make
decisions to be baptized or to come back
to you. Move upon their hearts, dear
God, for them to make that intelligent
choice. Bless the pastor, the leadership
of the church. Father, leadership is not
easy, but it's necessary. Give the
leaders wisdom from above their God that
they may lead this church not only
forward but upward and save every single
family when you come in Jesus name. Let
God's people say amen and amen. God
bless you. I love you. Stay faithful by
the power of the spirit of God. Amen.